death stranding is all about forming
connections and one of the most
important ways to do that is through the
games online social features while you
won't see other players objects you
leave in your game may end up in
somebody else's and vice versa
you could play des training offline but
you'd be doing yourself and other
players a disservice
here's how this critical feature works
when you first arrive in a new area
you'll be on your own but once you
connect a region to the chiral Network
you'll start to see other players
structures signs vehicles and lost cargo
some of the objects you leave behind
will show up in other players games you
can build a wide variety of structures
using a PCC that can help you and other
players traverse the world
these include bridges generators ladders
climbing ropes post boxes and
watchtowers bridges make it easy to
cross rivers and ravines generators
recharge batteries and vehicles ladders
make it easy to climb up cliffs while
climbing ropes make it easier to climb
down them post boxes offer a safe place
to store cargo and watchtowers let you
scout ahead there are even some
structures like roads that require a bit
of teamwork to build as you explore you
may come across objects called Auto
pavers once you and other players have
invested enough resources into an auto
paver
a road will be constructed however
structures and vehicles both yours and
other players are not permanent rain
will deteriorate them over time it takes
a while for structures to fall apart so
don't worry about their well being early
on see a sign you like or a vehicle or
structure that helped you out in a pinch
well then smash that like button
getting likes adds to your total pool of
social cash which increases your
reputation as a porter moving up the
ranks earns you bonuses such as
increased carry capacity and better
posture when under stress when you
interact with someone else's structure
you form a bridge link this means that
you are more likely to see their
structures in the future if you grow an
affinity for a certain person you can
even enter a strand contract with them
this means that you will see their stuff
in your world even more you can
establish a strand contract by entering
the bridge links menu after you've
unlocked it and selecting from the list
of players containing all the people
you've interacted with so that's how
multiplayer works in desk stranding like
I said before do not play this game
offline
not only will it be much tougher but
you'll be missing out on some of the
best aspects of the game for more deaths
training stuff make sure to stay tuned
to games but and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]